the founder of black lives matter was
never shy about what her organization
believed about the Middle East their
views always aligned with some of the
core tenants of
Hamas what does the black lives matter
movement have to do with Palestine I
know a lot of people ask that a lot of
black people ask that we have to be a
part of um uh Palestinian solidarity and
Palestine is our generation in South
Africa okay and yet CEO after CEO lined
up to support BLM and students across
America remember they were all pushed to
post in solidarity with black lives
matter not knowing really what they were
supporting all of them Lemmings now I
know what you're thinking okay maybe
this isn't fair maybe Patrice is kind of
an
outlier there is lots of common cause
between African-Americans and
Palestinians and that is not a new
relationship that's a relationship that
has been forged over decades uh as a
result of uh very similar uh feeling
conditions uh that folks are existing
in okay well she has a point about this
has been going on for some time but
maybe we should think okay being pro
Palestine it certainly doesn't mean that
they're anti-semitic right or or is that
wrong it's so important I believe in our
current generation of movement leaders
especially black folks to understand the
history of Black Liberation and our
relationships with Palestinian struggle
zionists have used anti-Semitic rhetoric
to uphold Jewish Supremacy and the
illegal state of
Israel but what about lower level
staffers of black lives matter they all
can't be in lock step what's going on in
Palestine is not a conflict it is ethnic
cleansing we as black people we know
occupation we know colonization we know
the taste of
Tas oh that that Linda sarur that almost
gave me a real bad case of dyspepsia
there so in Black lives matter
Affiliates across the country post
images and messages glorifying the
terror attack in Israel and the national
chapter refuses to condemn them don't
pretend like this hate was in present in
2020 joining me now former BLM activist
Xavier deaso Xavier does any of this
surprise you and explain if you would
the connection between the radicals in
Black lives matter and the uh
anti-semitic Sentiments of the Hamas
likee
organizations this doesn't surprise me
at all and first of all if what I'm
about to say makes you mad then don't
punch me go punch a Time Clock black
lives matter is filled with jobless
Godless hateful marxists and their
support for literal terrorism just
emphasizes that point there's no such
thing as being the good guy when you are
beheading babies and that's exactly what
Hamas is doing and I used to fall for
the lies of black lives matter and I
would often say that there are some good
people over there they're just misguided
but that is not the case especially
anymore cuz if you can stand behind an
organization that supports this level of
Devastation that is a direct reflection
of you and your values peace is easier
set than done but hatred is always a
conscious choice and black lives matter
chooses hatred every single day what's
your message to all of those big CEOs we
saw people uh the heads of major Fortune
500 companies Nike Apple uh the list
goes on and on Pepsi Pepsi I believe uh
who you know 2020 came around the of
love and they were rushing to the
cameras you know it was some about Floyd
but it was also standing in solidarity
with this group it was a reflexive level
of support they all wrote big checks did
they know what they were supporting or
they just wanted to get you know get any
of the leftists off their back at the
time it's definitely a combination of
both these people knew that BLM was a
scam they knew that BLM was full of
hatred but they're going to do whatever
it is that takes to or that it takes to
get the left to be on their side and for
the woke mob to not cancel them well I
think uh Business Leaders a few of them
are starting to wake up but we'll see
Xavier great to see you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else